.
LET'FRONT."
GREETED BY SOME YONE, HOW P
FELLOWIN THANKIENDS
FOR THOSE GENEUS WORDS.>>IAN ANA
ED TO STAND BEFORE YOU
GU
LERSHO,
FOLLOWING TRS  C
A
JOE BIDEN N FAIR SQUARE.
DONALD TRUMP STILL REFUSES TO
STWE HAVE MORE VS
OF TRUMPS STORL.
I WILL WWATCH.U THO HARDO
>>N YOU H DOUBT OF
WHAT THAT MAN WAS THERE TO DO.
HE THETOAS AM [ BLEEP ]
CAPITOYOU.>> ANY QSTN CHARGED W
LAS WAS ALSO H VIDEO.
RIG OFFICERS AND A METAL POLE A
THEM.
N  AED AT YOU SEEHERE
INCIDENTS WE SAWOFFICERS WERE B
SUFFAIN RY  FROM.
TRRS ARE STILL NONE OF THIS
HAPPENED.
THNG TE TOELSE.THE LATEST TARGE.
>> WHETHER THE FBIILBRING IT
ACTUALLY NOT REASONABLEM TO BR.
TO ASK WHO'STH
FBI ORGANIISR BEHI
THISG TO SPUN Y
YOHEARD, HE'S UNIGATION BY THE L
LOYAS OF WHAT
HAPPENh.
PROPAGANDTHIS WAS AN
ARMEINSURRP SUPPORTERS LOST
THEILID NOEM TAKING E LIVES OF V
AGA VI
THE 6tT WASTIS>> NONE OF THAT I.
HAT. IS WHAT
DONALD TRUMP L
ELS ORTERS AND S C
RESPONSIBLE?D THEM TO  HELL."
PROTECTED OSWHO ST HEARD SPOUTIN
LIES.
TRUMP, MIKE PENCE E CAPITOL ONY
HERE W
EVACUATED HE SHOUTING "HANG KE
EYAT WFTE.I DON'T KNF EE SN
>> SO NOCE DIDOTN THE ACTED WHY
THYIO
PRETEND LIKE IT NEVER HAPPENED.
PAULA REED I"OUTFRONT" IN
WASHINGTON UTONIGH
WHAT MORE ARE YOU LEAR F
TH?
>> GOOD EVENING, IT WAS EDWS OUI
NO YOU SEE SCOTTD P OSE LOOK OF.
ING TING AND SHOVING AN OFFICERH
.
HARGEDH 12 CRIMINAL
TSAULTING NGEROUS
PROSECUTORS SENDING THIS VIDEO
WHILE THIS HAVE BEEN, IT WAS NOI
CNN OV DOZEN OTHER
AGESBEEN FIGHTING TO
RELEASE THEM AS CHTHE
BEING UST STILL HA FOOLLANCE TA
NOT BEEN SEEN BY T PUBLIC.
NOW THE CLIPE BEEN
REVEALED, THEY CE AS SOME
REPUBLICAN MEMBEF CONGRESS  TO H
OF THAT DAY ANY OF WHO'SSPE ATTT
INCLUDING CNN CONTINUING TO
FIELGT FO                    ON
DAY.
KAT WITH ME
NOW IS DAN REP
ARE LOOKING HERE.
RIOTERS WERE TRYING TO BREAK IN
R N THESE
VIDEOSEASED.OTHER WA
OLENT THESE PEOPLE WERE.
>> IT IS
WATCH FOR A LOT OF UWH
APAR THIS.
I WAS THERE.
IT WAS MOMENT I WILL TAKE
ME FOR THE REST OFLIFE.
WHEN I SEES ATTACK
ITDS US THAT THESE
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WHIPPED U L
PROLIFILIAMERICS LITICS AND A
FORCE.
E RED MEMBEROF CONGRESS O REWRIT
COUE THEY HAVE CHANGE TH PRODUC
CORD WHATOOK PLACE.T REBL MEMBE
TELLING THEMSELV FAIR
LE
SE VS WITHYOUR OWN
IT INOPING THESE G
AND GIRLS, WHAT THEY
ABHERE.
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE IN
THESE LIES ALLOWING THEM IF
SHING NG THEM
J
POLIC IS A FIGHT AL
I STRUGGLE BECAUSE IAT
RESPONSIBLE RIGHT NOW FOR THE AH
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS, W WHO
THEY ARE.TH THE
INSURRECISE PEOPLE WHO
T
THOPLE WHO GAVE THE TRUTH,
THE ONEST BOTHERS ME T ARETIENT
BENEFITING A WHIPPEDP FAIRY
MODERATES THAT ARE WILLING TALO
TO OT AND CENTERF TH
ARGUMENT.
THEIR SILENCE IS HURTING THIS
COUNTRY.S
SILENT AND NOT CALL OU
REPUBLIC